(airplane whoosh)
- [Camera Man] Alright girly girl.
Oh, before and after.
(smooch)
- Hello.
- [Camera Man] You ready for
special surprise for you?
- Oh my goodness.
- [Camera Man] No movies
tonight, this was all joke, hoax.
Big hoax.
(speaking in foreign language)
Be my guest.
- Oh my goodness!
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
(speaking in foreign language.)
- What is up, Alexandra?
Happy Tuesday.
I wanted to thank you for being a fan
and thank you for being
excited to read my book.
Your husband, Daniel, reached out to me
and he wanted to get you
my book as a surprise gift
and then wrote to me to
say that he was worried
you might either go
out and buy it yourself
before he gave it to you or that you might
discover on your joint Amazon account
that he did, bought it for you
and he wanted to keep it a surprise.
He mentioned that you're a big fan.
I really appreciate that.
That he is also a fan,
but that you're much more of a fan
so we got to work on Daniel to get him
to be more of a fan.
Come on, Daniel bro, let's go.
We got to get watchin' some videos.
But, you know, I don't know that much more
you're up to, Alexadra,
but one, that's the name of my sister
so that's pretty cool and two,
I know you have a pretty special husband
who really cares about you and that goes
the extra mile to make things special.
So I admire that and I'm
a Daniel fan as well.
So, I hope you're having a great night.
This is launch day for
me so it's an insane day
and I just wanted to make
sure that I got this video
up for you as an extra special thank you
as part of the surprise gift.
So that's it.
Thank you for your loyalty
and all the awesomeness.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Enjoy the book.
Much love, go out, seize it.
(clapping and crying)
- [Camera Man] And book arrives tomorrow
but I got you Kindle edition.
- Thank you so much.
You have no idea how
much this means to me.
Thank you so much for doing this
with my amazing husband.
Oh, I'm so, so happy, speechless.
Have your book right here.
Going to start reading it tonight.
And my truly copy arriving tomorrow.
Oh, I couldn't wait for months.
You changed my life.
You don't even know like
my every day little things
my habits that I'm doing.
Like, I'm so grateful for you,
and thank you for putting
this awesome awesomeness
on the internet for everybody.
Thank you for showing me how much
you care for your fans.
I'm up to some amazing and huge things.
And I know I'm going to see you.
I'm going to meet you.
I'm going to tell you all about it.
And that's it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for doing this.
Good luck with your book
and with everything you do.
Say hi to Nina and your little boy.
And I'm going to continue to believe.
I'm going to share the love
with everybody around me.
Thank you.
(airplane whoosh)